>> John Doyle. >> Oh, no.
>> Dog's names. >> Red, blue, green, pink, butterfly,
Brooklyn, Bagel, Binky, Brownie, Bambi, Peanut. We really like
the way that Charlie Kirk thought about marriage. >> These
people can vote and have the same rights as you remember.
>> Maybe I'll find my perfect man. You know, you're not
going to find really anything at the bar or stuff like that.
So, yeah. all that. >> She loaded up all of her dogs and
she came to Charlie Kur Memorial hoping to find a guy. All right,
>> I told you she's not happy.
>> I knew it.
>> There's also the Channel 5 video. Okay, there's a sick
Channel 5 video on
what is it here? Sick new Channel 5 video on the Charlie Kirk
Memorial. Andrew Callahan, how do we think he handled it? He
said this about um the death penalty. He wanted public executions.
And I think it's very ironic that he got publicly executed. Too
many people are feeling bad for him. >> Uh-oh. Uh-oh. These
are the leftist. These are the crazy leftist influencers that
Benny Johnson told me about. >> I think we should respect
his beliefs. He didn't believe in empathy. >> So, I think
we should respect his beliefs and not have any empathy for >> What
was your emotional reaction like when you found out Charlie Kirk
was assassinated?
I I broke down crying. I went I was at work, unfortunately. I
went into a room and I I cried. I called my parents. I mean,
he's had such an impact on our lives. I felt like from a religious
standpoint, he just helped strengthen our faith. And from a political
standpoint, I felt like I should What is she talking about? >> Kyle
Writtenhouse. Let's go, dude. Kyle Written House >> standpoint,
he just helped strengthen our faith. And from a political standpoint,
I felt like I should never back down from what I believe in.
>> Such a heart. Such a heart for the black >> 25%
of of >> Hold on. Hold on. Uh Andrew Callahan's going to
do a vicious cut here. >> A heart. >> Hold on. >> Such
a heart for the black community. >> 25% of black youth
had were raised by a single mom. That's the number one issue
happening in the country. And it's not because of systemic racism.
He again he just wanted people to be better to recognize the
full potential.
>> I that would have that cut would have gone way harder
with like with any of his comments on like black surgeons, black
female surgeons, black female pilots. That would have been way
better >> to stop with the victim mentality and walk in
greatness as he knew that we >> Charlie Kirk
is the 13th disciple. >> What do you mean by that? >> Well,
the disciples all died bringing people to Jesus. They were martyed
bringing people to Jesus. So now Satan's dancing and thrilled
and I'm telling people if you voted for the for the Democrats
this last election, you voted for the cartels. >> Have
you always been so religious? >> No, because when I was
in Vietnam, I was killing people and I couldn't understand what
the hell was going on.
>> Amazing. Amazing. This idea that if you're fighting
a war and you're killing people, you can't be religious. >> You
can't be religious. I feel like that should be sort of totally
I feel like most people in the army are religious explicitly
like most people in the army are
I would imagine that's like a very highest in >> it's how
it's how they cope with right >> yeah I would imagine yeah
>> a lot of people or because they they turn to a higher
power they see a lot of horrible out there and they pray >> that
there's something else yeah >> no atheists in foxholes
yeah true >> that is the same >> why would God allow
this >> people are crying about
it It was just particularly funny to me because he's like, "No,
I wasn't always back when I was people. I wasn't." But now that
I'm done people, I have time to be like religious, right?
>> Uh, guys, what? There's no way this is real. Is there
Gregor Samsa? Is this real,
Chad? Is this real? >> Is what real? >> Gregor Samsa
reports. Okay. Possibly breaking news. Is Alex Jones unbanned
on YouTube? There's no way.
There's no no [__] way. Hey, Alex Jones is unbanned
on YouTube. Get the out of here. Hold on. Alex
Jones YouTube. There's no way. There's no way. I don't see anything
there. Go over to X. Sadly, it is true. Hold on. Alex Jones.
Mr. Alex Jones unbanned on YouTube. No way. YouTube channel.
Alex Jones live. YouTube.com.
>> James Comey is expected to be >> Alex Jones live.
He's back. Alex Jones live. Let's go.
Alex Jones returns to YouTube after Google's ban on polit political
speech is lifted.
Oh, you know what this is? >> You know what this is, right?
>> This is he's he's unbanning himself. He's making a new
channel and saying Google's announced that they've they've lifted
all their suspensions of people banned for political speech.
So, I'm making my account. I'm coming back. And I think really
Google's probably thinking they're going to do a um No, no, no,
no. I think Google's in my head Google's like thinking they're
going to do a process for people to come back. And I think Alex
just just made it
Google YouTube YouTube reinstates banned creators. Is this just
about their plan though or is this real? Cuz we'll see. Hold
on. YouTube reinstating. So this is Yeah, we we've covered this
or I I saw this at least that they're going to but this is uh
this is their plans. They don't have like some process. This
looks like Alex Jones just made a new account. Was like [__]
it. I'm back on YouTube. That's what it looks like to me.
Yeah, it's not a restored account. It's 2.868K subs.
So, he's just like, "Guess what, guys? I'm back. I'm unbanned.
I'm back on YouTube now. We're back, guys. We're back right now."
That's kind of That's kind of next level move cuz now they'd
have to ban him, right? Will make sure he never comes back. No,
no, no, no, no. You can't. Trust me, if they should have if they
should have unbanned Alex Jones or if they were going to, this
might work out in his favor because
that dude, you can't be the the platform that bans Alex Jones
with this administration right now. I just don't think that's
going to work out well for you. I think you YouTube wants none
of that smoke. Anyway, let's continue. >> Why aren't they
crying about the school shootings? I'm an educator. I have been
trained to die for children. We're supposed to jump in front.
Dude, this is How do they always find What do these people realize
that they just need to never talk to somebody? Like, don't ever
I I know a couple teachers who are like this. Okay, I do. And
it's like, I need you to realize that you guys need to never
talk ever about your beliefs.
Do not talk. Stop talking. Okay, please. For the love of God,
stop talking. You don't understand how harmful your [__]
>> I don't know. I think you should speak your truth. Some
reporter, some interviewer come up to me and ask me, "What do
I think about the gang rap on goats in India or what do I think
about Haiti?" I'mma start spin. >> Uh-huh. I This woman
is harmful to any cause she believes in. >> Front of the
gut. You're a Democrat. You will defend me. >> Counting
or not counting gang violence. >> What would you say resonated
>> to jump in front of the gut? Counting or not counting
gang violence. >> What would you say resonated the most
with you about his messaging? M well the message of hope even
though the things >> Wait did the most with you about his
>> M well
>> okay never mind. I thought this guy this guy almost
had the no I thought I thought I saw the mustache from the >> the
message of hope even though things may seem bleak. we have Christ,
but also he
kind of like the way he lived his life, like how he got married
early and how he talked about having kids really resonated with
me cuz I think a lot of that is a solution to a lot of the the
problems and the challenges that we're facing here in America.
>> He was Jesus on earth. He was like a living AI where
you could go and ask it a question and it would respond to you
but with God
>> literally none of these people understand how much how
far how far they've fallen. I just >> he was like he was
like chat GPT for God. You asked this guy has this person ever
heard of a pastor, a priest, anybody who works in the church
where you can ask them questions and they will just talk to you
about God. >> Literally anybody. And also you can chat
GPTt it. He's not you could just use chat GBT. Actually a human
being is not like chat GPT. Chat GBT is like chat >> Unironic
Postadist feels the need for us to point out that these people
can vote and have the same rights as you.
>> there are
people like Charlie Kirk, the pastors of Charlie Kirk actually
use chat GPT to make their weekly sermons.
>> No, they absolutely do. probably. Listen, the Bible's
a complicated book. It's a very long book. >> They have
like they have priest seminars and stuff like that where they
discuss how they feel about pastors using AI
>> Oh, that is like one of the easiest places you could
get away with it, too. >> It's very funny. >> You
ever you ever just sometimes think Ted Kazinski was right about
everything? >> What who's that again? Oh, the uni
happened before. Remember? >> Absolutely. Thank you, Charlie.
What's dog name? >> Red, blue, green, pink, butterfly,
Brooklyn, Bagel, Binky, Brownie, Bambi, Peanut. We really like
the way that Charlie Kirk thought about marriage.
>> This is the AI woman, right? Has all these dogs.
Uh, this person, here's the here's the sad thing. Don't you just
wish you could like life swap with this person? I bet you this
person's like tremendously happy somehow. They just got a bunch
of dogs. They're like out of their mind. They think Charlie Kirk
was chat GPT for God. Like, their life is probably simple. They're
probably happy. I have like other thoughts going on and it's
like I just wish I could be >> I just wish I could I wish
life could be this easy for me, you know? >> Yeah. And
there's someone who's high on fentinel right now leaned over
next to a bench. They're so high they don't just sit down on
the bench. They're just like leaned over. That person's feeling
very happy in that moment.
I bet you're not jealous of them. H
>> God.
Anyway, bonds you but with God. >> Prodigal son.
Listen, Extreme Dad is happy. I know it. I know it. You know
it. He's a happy >> None of it happened before. Remember?
>> Absolutely. Thank you, Charlie. Good seeing you again.
>> What's all your dogs names? >> Red, Blue, Green,
Pink, Butterfly, Brooklyn, Bagel, Binky, Brownie, Bambi, Peanut.
We really like the way that Charlie Kirk thought about marriage.
I'm single and in my 40s and maybe there's like been a little
bit of a spark. Maybe I'll find my perfect man. you know, you're
not going to find really anything at the bar or
stuff like that. So, yeah. All that. >> She loaded up all
of her dogs and she came to Charlie Kirk's memorial hoping to
find a guy. All right. >> I told you she's not happy. >> I
knew it.
>> Oh, I have 10 dogs, so I don't really need a man, but
it would be nice maybe by that one. >> What about Charlie's
message? >> Dude, I'm sorry. I need to switch this over.
I needed uh I needed to do something for effect there. Can we
uh Thank you. >> resonated with you most. >> The
fact that he
swung the boat. Uh >> play that back. What do you mean
play that back? I Dude, it's already depressing. What do you
mean play that >> Good seeing you again. >> What's
all your dogs names? >> Red, blue, green, pink, butterfly,
Brooklyn, Bagel, Binky, Brownie, Bambi, Peanut. We really like
the way that Charlie Kirk thought about marriage. I'm single
and in my 40s and maybe there's like been a little bit of a spark.
Maybe I'll find my perfect man. You know, >> Dude, why
did Andrew Why did Andrew zoom in on this guy on Bill? Is it
Bill the Butcher? William the Butcher. The guy's name. Oh, Private
Huff. Thank you to the five gifted. >> That's two more
hours. Let's go.
>> Thank you. Thank you. >> Wait, what were you saying,
though? Cut you off. >> He's zooming on on this guy
perspective husband for her, right?
>> The animals, the dogs are going to love his mustache.
>> Maybe. I just I feel like this guy looked lonely.
Old and lonely. Old and lonely. Old and lonely. They'd be perfect.
I don't think the mustache factored in. >> No, but I think
he factored in that mustache to keep people the way. >> You're
not going to find really anything at the bar or
stuff like that. So, yeah. Although I have 10 dogs, so I don't
really need a man, but it would be nice to maybe find that one.
>> What about Charlie Kirk's message resonated with you
most? >> The fact that he >> How do the dogs Okay,
I There's just so many white women flags going off there. How
do the dogs
help with your need for a man? Please, can you can we uh Hello.
>> I have more questions. How do you start naming your
dogs after colors and then after the fourth color, you just switch
over to something different?
No idea. I would like to know her system. Okay. >> Maybe
she asked Charlie Kirk and Charlie
>> Can we get her socials? Let's have her >> I don't
That wasn't That wasn't direction, guys. That wasn't direction
to any action. >> Swung the boat as a single. >> Please
find her. Bring her to me. >> Okay, never mind. >> And
then all of a sudden, he passes
and his voice just gets louder. People don't die for a lie. They
die for the truth. Have you heard some of the more outlandish
theories about about that about why he was assassinated? >> Yeah,
I have and I don't care. >> Totally. Where do you think
the Republican party goes from here? >> Goes from here.
>> Oh, and it increases
the Democrats know they were losing and all they have is to
and violence. >> And I think what makes this kind of worse
is now Nick Fuentes is like up >> Elon Musk, you weren't
born here. Milo, you're a Je and you weren't born here. Can Owens,
your husband wasn't born here. Go the [__] home.
>> That's what happens when I think you take out somebody
like Charlie Kirk. Now you get like Nick Fuentes is now the next
guy up. >> I'm the real
>> uh you you miss a lot of people in
>> Also, I think this guy was coming up regardless of what
happened with Charlie Kirk. They they don't even there's no overlap
there. That's the weird thing. people are like I do think there's
like a bit of a power vacuum for like control in the conservative
party, but in terms of like who people are going to go to for
media, there not a lot of Christians who are like Protestant
Christians, Protestant Zionist Christians who are going to go,
"Oh yeah, let's go Nick Fentes is the next guy up." Like, no,
that is not these are not the same
>> Hey, uh JD Vance, any any statement any statement why
everybody thinks that the only person next in line was Charlie
Kirk, Mr. vice president. Do you have any feelings about this?
>> JD's like I'm next in line. I talk about >> Take
out somebody like Charlie Kirk. Now you get like Nick Fuentes
is now the next guy up. >> Wait, hold on. You you're misunderstanding
me, Chernobike, cuz Nick is benefiting, but it's in a totally
different way. It's not it's not from his uh it's not from audience
overlap. It's not like he's suddenly winning because of that.
He's winning in totally different ways. All right. But I think
it's it's disjoint from Charlie Kirk and there being a vacuum
in terms of that media ecosystem. >> I'm the realest [__]
on the internet that's in the middle of my generational
>> You took out some dude who was laidback, you know, politically
correct in like a Republican sense. Now you got this Mexican
white kid who's like, "We need only white people," you know?
So >> where do you think the future of the Republican party
is?
>> So anybody who tweeted about this recently or who talked
about this? I saw some Discord log. Oh, it was it was the Red
Scare Pod thing that I see I saw that somewhere. There's like
a post in the Red Scare Pod uh subreddit that was basically like
some like Mexican dude that I work with is just listening to
Nick Fentos on his lunch break and laughing and nodding along.
And it's like the dude doesn't even look like a little bit white.
Like he is like fullon he looks like he grew up in like the jungles
of Peru. Okay. He is actually
>> and there's no part of him that is remotely white. It's
like okay I
I Yeah, I don't know. The the the question was how did this happen?
Aztec. Well, I said I said Incan because I said the jungles of
Peru stand. >> It's going to go along the Charlie Kirk
router. I guess I don't think if you think about Nick Fuentes,
you don't really see I don't think he'd be pulling a crowd like
this. It's not to say anything against Nick Fuentes and like
bashing him in any way, but like Erica >> Oh, that's weird.
Wait, why is this guy's wearing a Turning Point USA lanyard?
He's got the white America verse or sorry, the white MAGA hat,
the 47. Okay. The the Trump hat. Why would he be worried about
insulting Nick Fentes? Not to say anything bad about Nick Fentes
>> like this. Not to say anything against Nick Fuentes
and like bashing him in any way, but like Erica Kirk has been
named the new CEO of TPUSA. So, we have that. And I think she
will do a really great job. Another person that's more maybe
closer to Charlie Kirk in my mind. Maybe might be like a
>> Hold on. We got to guess who's closer to Charlie Kirk
in this guy's mind.
Um, I know Masterson has said he's next in line. He's number
one now. Like proportion of his face or something like >> Oh,
that is a good metric. He is the He's now the undisputed number
one. >> Number one squish face. Yeah. Yeah. >> Okay,
that's fair. That's totally fair. >> All the other that
Charlie Kirk talks about, I don't think gives a [__]
about taking up that mantle.
>> Yeah, I don't think so. There's the turning. There's
the Daily Wire guys, Matt Walsh. Uh, Michael Nolles.
There's
Who the else is there? There's not Candace. No, not Candace.
Not Tucker, really. Tucker's too old. Tucker can't do it. Tucker
can't make it work, man. I don't know. There's like no other
young guys coming up. Brett Cooper.
No, I don't think so. >> But you're you're just looking
at influencers, right? >> Yeah, I'm just looking at influencers.
>> Okay. Because I would say >> nobody really knew
about Obama until maybe his second year into Senate. >> You
find you find a guy who's doing like revival gettogethers in
the South, right? Who's like charismatic
and you groom that guy for like six months to a year and you
get him out there debating like college kids, right? Like
a preacher. You get a preacher to lead TBUSA. Like a young preacher
who's compelling. I think I think that's like who I would think
could take this over. Probably that person is an influencer anyway,
right? I doubt anybody's like doing, you know, >> Well,
that's the problem. Okay. You can't get a preacher. You You actually
You have to find someone >> You can't get a sincere preacher.
>> That's why you have to find someone who is so new in
their faith or they turned to their faith because they were like
addicted to drugs or something. Somebody with like a a background
that you can manipulate better because anyone who's like truly
a Christian, they're going to start thinking for themselves.
>> Right. And I'm saying I think I think that's where they
go though. I think they go to like Christian people like like
someone who's not quite as online. Maybe somebody who's on Tik
Tok doing like Christian right-wing Christian influence on Tik
Tok or something >> on Tik Tok. >> I think that's
where they would go cuz everybody else is old. Their entire media
ecosystem is old as other than
>> like
the only young people there. >> It has to be someone who
can have an online influencer presence or you're talking about
>> Yeah, they have to be able to do that
Yeah, I think I Yeah, I don't know. I can't think of somebody
who could like take his place. Now that I'm like,
oh man,
now that I actually think about it, Charlie Kirk might have been
kind of indispensable just in that he wasn't old as like all
of the rest of these people are old as >> a John Doyle.
>> And I would like to see
>> John Doyle. >> Oh, no. You can't get the guy who
sits around. They're not even debating college students.
They pretend. Oh, we're debating college uh college women. No,
you guys pick only fans women. You guys pick prostitutes and
bring them on. You literally come through and look for who who
didn't even make it to college, who dropped out and are selling
pictures of their
>> and then the few that you get on that are educated.
You make sure that they're just one in a sea full of
bad representatives.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> They're like the one orc that could
fight. Okay. But you only see the army get taken out. Don't worry,
it's a Lord of the Rings reference. You don't >> I think
I
>> what you were saying the other day about like Fuentes
is thinking about branching out marrying two different ideologies.
I think they have to pull away from the Christian. They I think
they have to pick someone who is who believes in freedom of religion
and has respect for God and is is Christian but doesn't see themselves
as a preacher. And so they avoid that and that'll be a breath
of fresh air and it'll pull in more people. >> Maybe they
could go in that direction >> that that it comes off as
humble, but you hide the the weakness, which is they'd be talking
out their ass. >> Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Um that's I don't think
that's a weakness. I think more people in the US are performative
in their faith and sincere. Uh I think I don't think it's a weakness.
I think >> the weakness would be to hear them talk.
>> like Erica can get scrutinized every time she tries
to speak.
>> Am I lost? >> No. Well, I don't know. I actually
don't know. But I'm You were saying So, it sounded to me like
you were saying they get somebody who isn't sincere in their
faith because you don't want to have them go further down the
Christian pipeline. And >> you don't want them because
the more you are a grifter if you go into politics. Okay. You
do become an idol if you >> I'm telling you that I think
most people are not sincere in their faith. Especially anybody
who would be near politics at all. I don't think they're sincere.
They find somebody who's that that's going to be a prerequisite
is somebody who's not like sincerely
>> Christian. Somebody who will put their want somebody
who's going to put >> faith above Turning Point USA. >> Exactly.
Primary requirement. And that's why picking someone who even
imagines themselves that they are like of their faith, they're
going to start saying things that offend people or they they'll
either become too serious or they won't be serious enough if
they have this if they have the guise of, "Oh, I'm humble. I'm
not going to speak on this. I'm just going to let my pastor speak
about it," which most Democrats did. Most Democrats
acknowledge God. Obama always acknowledged God. Never spoke on
it like he was a pastor. >> Yeah. That's what people like.
>> That's what people like. I don't know if that's Turning
Point's identity, but if maybe if they pivot right now when they
lose Charlie Kirk, maybe it's the one point they could pivot
to something else. Yes. But then they'd be I don't I think there's
almost certainly given Erica Kirk named herself CEO and is like
taking it over. I think there's almost no way that they're even
going to get somebody else. I think she's going to try to make
it work herself somehow and I don't think it's going to go well.
But I like >> Well, that's great for me as a Democrat.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. for sure.
>> All right. Um, let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Oh,
they were discussing, right? He just said John Doyle. I was like
trying to remember where we were in the video. He just said his
his pick to lead Turning Point USA would be >> a really
great job. Another person that's more maybe closer to Charlie
Kirk in my mind. Maybe might be like a John >> And I would
like to see uh Trump Jun, you know, Don Jr. and Eric and JD Vance
and Baron one day be president. And uh maybe even my own nephew
one day be >> I can see it. Yeah. Thank you. >> I
am actually really energized seeing all these people here to
worship God and to worship Charlie. I think it's beautiful. I'm
holding back tears right >> Did you guys know Charlie?
I know that the floor seats are like friends and family kind
of deal. >> We did not know. Sorry. Why did he even bring
up Obama? Trump literally holds a Bible upside down and just
so long as he says, "Oh, I believe in God. That was God saved
me." Just so long as he says that every once in a while >> he's
got the evangelical vote. Yeah. >> They don't have to do
anything.
>> That's that's how I see it. I think there's a lot of
people who just don't give a if they're not sincere. They don't
care if the person they're following is sincere. They just want
>> just just get rid of abortion. Okay,
>> She said to worship God and to worship
>> Wait, did she hold on? I missed that. >> Was the
woman with her nephew, right? >> Do and Baron one day be
uh Trump, you know, Don Jr. and Eric and JD Vance and Baron one
day be president and uh maybe even my own nephew one day be president.
>> I can see it. Thank you. >> I am actually really
energized seeing all these people here to worship God and to
worship Charlie. I think it's be >> Oh, to worship God
and to worship Charlie. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> Beautiful. I'm holding back tears right >> Did
you guys know Charlie? I know that the floor seats are like friends
and family kind of deal. >> We did not know him, but we
saw him all the time. I mean, we're like what?
>> Why do you >> Oh my god. Charlie Charlie Kirk's
groupies are like 50-year-old white women. That's crazy. Although
the other girl was younger, but >> also I don't believe
she stalked him all the time. >> Okay. Why not? >> No.
I feel like stalkers, they're usually like pretty thin. They're
pretty in shape. They can >> in small places. >> If
she was stalking, it would have required following him on foot
and she clearly wasn't attempting to do that. Is that the direction
you're going in?
>> You think Charlie Kirk was assassinated? >> Mean.
Oh, I I would really base it off of basically what the
uh Tyler Robinson said where he said that he was like he thought
that he was spreading hate in that sense which in my opinion
like yes like to some people who might not have maybe the best
worldview or maybe like who are just in a bad place might think
that because maybe Charlie Kirk might seem like he's actually
you know berating you for the way that you are you know living
your life or things
Intrepid Gamer pointing out for us that Cherry is wrong and there
have been fat stalkers before. Wow. >> Oh, Baby Reindeer.
>> That's like one that that is so rare. They made a Netflix
series on it. Shut
>> Berating you for the way that
>> probably is Selena Selena Stalker. Selena Gomez, maybe.
>> No. Is it Selena? I thought he meant Selena like the
singer. >> Oh, I >> the Mexican singer. >> I
got no idea. who are, you know, living your life or things like
that. >> I was born as a man and now I'm a woman. >> Okay.
No, but you don't become a woman just because you dress like
a woman. >> My mom's from Mexico. My dad's in Syria. >> So,
when she came here, did she know she was breaking the law? She
was like, I
17. So, yeah. >> Did she know? >> She probably know.
>> Okay. Therefore, you should go back to your country
of origin. If you knew that you were invading somebody's home,
I don't have sympathy for you. >> I feel like it was for
religious reasons. I think there >> that was actually a
better clip than I didn't see that clip before.
That's that guy doesn't believe in birthright citizenship. I
didn't think that's a pretty radical position to not believe
in birthright citizenship, right? To think that the uh the Constitution
is just wrong on that. I think that's pretty extreme. >> People
that don't feel comfortable in his faith and him going out speaking
and there's a religious revival going on. He was touching people.
He was getting out >> I mean, I think we became tolerant
about things that were not correct. I I feel like we have a a
generation that doesn't understand what this nation was built
on. They don't understand their rights. I I think unfortunately
when you pull God out of regular day life, you start to let evil
in. >> They were wrong, but they don't want to accept it,
so they for it. >> Yo yo yo. >> Oh, hell no.
>> They killed him for it. >> Go back.
>> Wait, you don't like that black guy? >> Evil in.
>> They were wrong, but they didn't want to accept it,
so they killed him for it. Yo yo yo yo yo. >> That's That's
her nephew, by the way.
>> That's that white lady's nephew.
>> They were wrong. >> Hold on.
>> That's That's her nephew. >> Oh my goodness.
That's how she punishes
>> they they groom this kid. Okay. They groom this kid
into being MAGA. >> That's how that's how they punish the
family member that interraially
married and had a kid. Get out thing going on >> They turn
him into MAGA. Yeah.
That's [__] >> But they didn't want to accept
it, so they killed him for it. >> Yo yo yo yo yo. What
is up, brothers and sisters? This is Andrew Callahan, Channel
5 News. You guys have noticed whether or not
I'm right now
using this code. Nah, but for real, supporting ground news means
helping to support us, which means that we can keep making dope
ass bipartisan videos like this and giving y'all coverage that
isn't watered down or even worse, dictated by corporate interests.
So stay informed and most importantly, don't let the media, >> this
guy's got his chank speech down, >> tell you what to think.
All right, back to the mean streets of Glendale, >> What
do you think is the biggest threat to American values? >> Swag
rating uh like seven out of 10 >> today. Wokeism. You can't
be transgender because God >> to American values today.
>> To the mean streets of Glendel.
>> Wow. It's not It's not Russia or China. It's wokeism.
>> What do you think is the biggest threat to American
values today? >> Wokeism. You can't be transgender because
God chose a gender for you already. And the challenge is to work
with it. You not throw it away or think >> The challenge?
What was your challenge? What was he talking about? Uh the PTSD
from burning all of those Vietnamese people to death. >> No,
but with his gender.
>> is he just admitting I I'm closeted?
>> I don't I don't know. >> I don't know.
>> You can't be transgender because God chose a gender
for you already. And the challenge is to work with it,
not throw it away or think you can judge him. >> Oh, you
feel like he's speaking from personal experience on what the
challenge is. >> Yeah. You were You were made a man by
God. That's the challenge.
>> Listen, I had to deal with it. Okay. I had to deal with
it. You have to deal with it now. You guys think is the biggest
threat to American values right >> Very good. >> It
literally tells >> Dude, that was a weird dynamic >> to
American values right now. >> Very good. >> It literally
>> very good.
>> Uh-huh. really tells people that you can have four wives
and beat those wives. And also, the prophet Muhammad had a nine-year-old
wife. So, I don't think that's representative of American values
or values of the West. Anyway, >> is it okay to have another
religion besides Christ? >> Not in America
because our Constitution is based on Judo Christian values.
>> Dude, this
get this guy out of here. >> People don't even know the
propaganda. They can't even recite back the propaganda. in any
effective way. They just judo. Yes, judo as in like they're I
don't know. They're wrestling people with Christian values, I
guess. Judo. Judo Christian.
But like they don't even know the talking points. Like this is
the sad thing is like you're like we could beat them in the marketplace
of ideas, brother. These people are not in the marketplace. They're
not in the bizaar. They're not in they're not even within a thousand
miles of whatever marketplace of ideas. They don't care. They
just they don't care. They've picked a side. They picked a side
when their brain still worked and they're just going to vote
against you no matter what. There's no winning their vote. >> I
expect this when it's like random subway
interviews. It's like you're catching people off guard. They're
not really politically
uh interested, invested, or anything like that. And they're just
on their way to work and you're like, "Okay, where is Alaska
in the country?" And they just don't know how to answer.
>> These people are at Charlie's memorial >> and
like Charlie was murdered. Like they literally should have their
their thoughts on this
like like
wokeism I guess. Wouldn't it be like political violence like
rising political tensions? Honestly, even Democrats but if you're
a Muslim, a Sharia law Muslim, you believe that you have to Christians.
If you're a communist, you believe
>> I don't think that's actually true. I don't think that's
true at all. I think I think so it's it's true. Not true. I think
they think they have to be the dominant group, but I don't believe
that if they win like some kind of war that they're about, you
know, massacring people of different faiths. They're fine with
other faiths existing under them, which isn't necessarily a good
thing or awesome, but
yeah, demi status is a lesser citizenship though. It's a lesser
per a lesser way of living. But it's like it's not that they
will just murder you, right? That's that's the unfortunate thing
is people believe that oh, Muslims would just murder you. Arabs
would just murder you. No, not necessarily. Maybe he's talking
about Wahhabism. I guess something along those >> That
you have to control the world. Well, we don't control the world.
We're not looking to control the world. We conquered the
>> uh if unironic postidist I'll put this in terms you
can understand. Imagine Israel levied an additional tax on all
Palestinians. Would that be a problem? Would that be discriminatory?
Would that be marking them as lesser citizens in an apartheid
system? The answer, obvious answer is yes.
Jesus [__] Christ. >> The world in World War
II. The whole world was making sense for you now. The bad guys.
>> No, really. Japan is Japan. Germany is Germany. We didn't
keep it for ourselves. We're for freedom in in the >> Losing
Charlie's really sad, but I think it created a million more Charlies
and I look forward to seeing what the future has to bring to
the United States and around the world. >> Have you heard
the theory that Charlie Kirk was assassinated
>> to destroy Hold on, hold on. I just had a I just had
a vision, okay, of the moment Charlie Kirk was shot. There's
like a million people who saw that video and like instantly,
okay, they watched that video and they they saw him go down and
then their face contracted by like three inches in every direction.
Their face contracted, they created a million Charlies. So many
compressed faces.
>> I
It's just a random reaction to seeing that video. Okay. It's
It's crazy. >> Cracked from the Epstein files. No, that's
not true. >> I have never spoken to President Trump about
the Epstein files. >> How old are you? >> I'm 14.
14. So, it seems like Charlie did a lot for young men specifically.
When did you first find out about Charlie Ker >> in the
2024 election? I started seeing his videos. >> What resonated
with you most about his
>> His how he would debate and stay calm and also how he
would prove them wrong as well. >> Where did you go to
college? >> I went to Arizona State. >> Okay. Would
you say that there was like a lot of liberal messaging in the
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Yes. So, I graduated in 2020. I played
>> that uh that poor black kid. It's been
>> uh did college sports. We were all required. I mean,
I wasn't on the team when they started mandating this, but it
was vaccines. You had to wear the the like LGBTQ pride shirts
to honor that. And so I missed a lot of it in the sports, but
>> you will you will love the gays. Okay. Mandatory gay
support.
I think she's she's probably talking about like wearing a pin
on your jersey or something, right? I'm guessing >> by
the time I had graduated, it was ushered in. And even my classes
I felt were very liberal leaning. >> Um it was unfortunate
what happened. It was terrible what happened and disgusting what
happened. But when you see the Charlie Kirk effect, this is all
he ever wanted is for a revival within the United States of America
and all over the world. This is all he ever dreamed and hoped
for. This is all he ever preached. So to see it come true.
Unfortunately, when it comes to his
>> it's it's a bittersweet moment. >> Do you think
freedom of speech is under
>> I do. I do.
>> Oh god. No. Go back to the Go back to the cringe Republicans.
Go back to the cringe conservatives. Do not show me this progressive
lady again. She's about to say some I can't possibly defend.
>> Bipartisan reporting from Brown News. >> Andrew,
no. Andrew, stop. It's too painful. Okay, I'll point out there's
only like one of these crazy ladies. Okay, there's a bunch. He's
got his pickings in the Charlie Kirk Memorial. There's only one
of these ladies. All >> Can't censor the truth. Jimmy Kimmel
got fired for making a joke, which is just ridiculous. Ridiculous.
Like, he was even asked to apologize. He refused, which I'm I'm
proud of him for refusing. I think, >> you know, if they
can say what they want, why can't we, you know? I don't think
there's any
>> right or wrong
>> for anybody. They're just they believe what they believe,
you know, and you can't fault them for that. >> How did
you feel about Jimmy Kimmel being taken off air?
>> The ratings, he didn't have it. That's probably the
only reason. Wasn't political. Just he >> there's just
so many people without the light in them. And I don't know. I
don't know what to do about it. >> Didn't have the ratings.
>> I actually don't like it cuz ultimately Charlie wouldn't
have liked that. Charlie is the the ultimate advocate for the
freedom of speech. >> When people stop talking, that's
when violence happens. >> So if there's any type of government
coercion
in regards to that, that's something that Charlie would have
been against. Even when it comes to disparaging comments, he
would let the people come, you know, about the college campus.
Charlie would let the people come to the mic and say what it
is that they wanted to say and he would debate them in good faith.
And if you know, freedom of speech does come with its its risks
and that includes those who want to use disparaging remarks to
put people down and then try to destroy other one another. But
at the end of the day, he still stood for it because that's the
that's the American way. That's how we get any type of uh headway
in our country is through dialogue. And that's why I'm I'm uh
I'm a bit upset at the conservative response when it comes to
Jimmy Kimmel. >> All right, here's the thing. Again, I'm
going to tell you truth again.
The population of America is 4% of the world's population. We're
4% of the world's population.
You had a 96%
>> Is that Is that another Hold on. >> No, it's not.
Wait, what is that? Carl
>> Wait, is this like It's too skinny to be Carl Rove.
Is that
>> That's not Carl Rove, is it? The Is it?
Oh, no. It's way way way too skinny to be Carl Rove. Never mind.
It's way too skinny to be Carl Rove.
My bad. My bad. He He almost looks like an older version of Carl
Rove. Okay.
You had a 96% chance of being born someplace else. And God gave
you the gift of being born free in the United States of America.
What are you going to do with the gift? We got to come together,
man. Just one love, one one uh one idea, one country, man. We're
all in the same uh in the same battle, man. I think America's
got a lot of work to do, >> People need to start. >> Thank
you. Thank you, sir. Listen, guys. America's got a lot of work
to do, okay? We ought to come. We all got to come together. One
side, one battle, one people, one fight. Okay? >> Start
having mutual respect for each other. And we need to stop using
dehumanizing languages like calling each other fascist white
supremacist racist when we're all Americans and we're all >> ew
socialism TPUSA fascist fascist racist all these things. I think
the political divide in the news media, they will say things
that aren't facts and they will get people hyped up and believing
that Charlie's a racist or the people that follow Trump are horrible,
bad, evil people. When >> Andrew W right there, we saw
who he transitioned to, right? For evil people, if you're watching
audio only, okay, you need to pull the screen up right now. Just
watch the transition for evil people. It's worth it. Okay, hold
on. We need to see this cut. We're going to give you two. No,
I'm going to give you like five seconds. Five to go get your
phone or go get your device. Go sit at your computer. Three,
four, three, two, one. Okay. >> Racist or the people that
follow Trump are horrible, bad, evil people.
>> Horrible, bad, evil people. Cut to Steve Bannon looking
very alcoholic today. Looking incredibly alcoholic. >> I
wouldn't have even recognized that as Steve Bannon.
>> Oh, h how not? I don't know what the [__]
he looks like from the side. I would need to see his back. >> That's
just obviously Steve Bannon.
>> I don't know. There's just I would never mistake Steve
Bannon for another human being. He is like a unique looking human
being. He is always red. He is always completely red and his
hair is just always like greased back, slick back. It's Yeah,
this is like I'd never forget this guy. I never It couldn't be
anyone else. when really it's the media spinning words and and
using their words to cause harm to people who believe
>> The trilogy of freedom is our family, our country, and
our God.
>> Do you think he'll forgive you if you throw your life
back in his face when you commit stuff?
That's a greater sin to me by spitting in God's face. How's that
going to work? How's that going to go? carry the pain because
carrying
the war you're people and to carry that it's not easy. >> It
works on you and especially when you're 20 especially then. So
I'm giving you insight as to what post-traumatic stress is and
how we're trying to deal with it. >> He's got some insight.
I believe >> I do wood shop therapy to help me. It keeps
me busy.
You see? So I'm making something and I'm ah look at that. and
I could give it to my family and they go, "Oh, wow. Thank you
very much."
>> Okay, that's actually a good story. Okay, I I like that
story, >> you know. So, that works for me. >> I mean,
it also explains a lot. I'm pretty sure the the dust from the
sanding of like wood is like pretty poisonous. It's like really
bad for you.
>> So, I can say, "Okay,
I can get off my river boat
>> and I'm going to give you insight on that, please."
Okay.
Some veterans wonder if God will forgive them because they don't
understand the difference between and murder.
>> What's the difference? >> You kill someone because
your life is in danger. So, you're protecting America because
they're attacking the world and they want to destroy America.
So, you're them. All right. But murder is I don't like that guy.
I'm going to plan on taking him out. >> You see the difference?
>> Okay. So that's the difference. >> The event is
over. Trump ended it. Honestly, it was a pretty big disappointment
on Trump's end. We had some really good speeches in there. Obviously,
Saddam couldn't get in. He has a face condition. So, I had to
go >> I think we found an answer
to autism. How about that? >> How was it outside?
>> what a goofy How how the do you announce that at somebody's
f at somebody's like >> Yeah, dude. That's
>> that guy. This Trump guy. I don't know if you guys know
this. This Trump guy is kind of wild. What is this?
Never mind. >> You imagine if uh if his kids were there,
they turned to his mom. Mom, did you take Tylenol and all? >> I
will just be a pay. >> Oh, hold on. Reven.
>> The guy said it. Abortion isn't murder when your life
is in danger. >> Oh, he kind of did, didn't he? He kind
of did. He said his murders were justified in battle because
his life was in danger. So what's his opinion on abortion? I
guess so. He can't be against the saving the life of the mother.
Although I will say I think most Republicans aren't against that.
I think you have to be really extreme to be against that. Like
the life of the mother exception. I think you got to be really
extreme about it to to not believe. >> You mean there's
a couple little like >> Come right here, dude. I'm not
nobody but Jesus. >> Jump over. Jump over. Jump over. Talk
your [__] See? Talk [__] Jump over. Talk
[__] then. Jump over. >> I'm telling you. You
would rather jack up in the phone booth than >> I'm saying
talk [__] >> You're spreading nothing but you
die for >> How stupid you are. >> You know, uh, Yogi
Barrett said it's hard to make predictions, especially about
the future. >> The Westboro Baptist Church came there,
>> The Westboro Baptist Church did come. >> That
was pretty cool. >> Charlie Kirk was a fake Christian.
God still hates. >> That's pretty sick. I saw Kyle Written
House inside. >> Yeah. Yeah. I tried to >> blast
from the past. >> Ask him some questions. I wanted to ask
him if like he had any sympathy for the shooter given like his
history. >> That's true. >> Uh but yeah, I mean everyone
thought
>> what the [__] >> That was Andrew.
So I had a
>> uh that's a that's actually kind of a [__]
up question asked Kyle Written House. Hey, you know when you
got chased down the street by those people and you had to people
to to like save your own life? Remember that? You think you feel
any sympathy for this guy who just like shot Charlie Klie Kirk
dead like a dog in this political rally? You got any sympathy
for him? No. Oh wow. >> A good time. Honestly, inside was
like it was like a very loving environment and then the speakers
got to talking and it was like war cries. >> I hate my
opponent
>> and I don't want the best for them. I'm sorry. I am
sorry, Erica. Father, forgive them
for they not.
>> That was how he was put down. An ironic postadist like
a loved family pet of Christine Gnome. All right, that's how
>> know what they do. >> To be fair though, the shooter
far more effective. Christine Gnome missed. Okay, she needed
to go back for more bullets. >> Oh my, she missed so many
times. >> She missed. She had to go back for more >> You
have no idea. The dragon you have awakened. You have no idea
how determined we will be to save this civilization,
to save the West, to save
this republic.
>> America was his home and he was willing to die for it.
>> Corporatism mixed with Christianity and like vague religious
identitarianism.
Uh just kind of all wrapped up into this one thing where like
the enemy is evil. >> You have nothing. You are nothing.
You are wickedness. You are jealousy, you are envy, you are hatred,
>> you are nothing. >> And uh yeah, I don't know.
It was a super strange feeling, but everybody was really nice
like you know to us which was cool. >> Yeah. I notic that
people were people were like hella chill with me as well. You
know what I mean? >> But other than that, I mean it was
fun. >> Oh, hold on. We got donation for the >> It's
hot as here. They keep saying Charlie K's in heaven. Lucky him.
He's not in Phoenix. You know what I mean? It's hot as hell out
here. Channel 5 >> That's a pretty good video. I don't
mind that.
All right.
Listen, that was that was fun.
Them them Republicans real wacky though. The